hello I am David Kaplan and I am NOT an
expert but I hope in this series to
learn as much as possible and explain it
to you the best way I can I want to talk
about something very serious I want to
talk about the universe as a fruitcake
you see a great description of the
expansion of the universe is that of a
infinite fruitcake which is expanding in
all directions at some constant rate
where the little pieces of fruit are
galaxies and places where you and I live
that description is great because it
matches the geometry of the universe an
infinite fruitcake has so no center and
so everywhere you are you see things
expanding away from you and the things
that are farther away are expanding
faster so that's exactly what is
happening we know the universe is
expanding no in the sense of we have
much more evidence than for most things
you know in your daily life so we are
very convinced of that well we don't
really understand is why the fruitcake
is so uniform why there's pieces of
fruit roughly at constant intervals and
why the density of the fruitcake may
make it taste quite bad but at the same
time it's uniform throughout the cake
there's a idea that in the beginning or
very early times of the universe the
universe expanded incredibly quickly in
all directions and everything got flat
and everything got uniform and we call
that cosmic inflation and we wonder if
that's actually true it's our best guess
but we don't know and it was one of
those models where when it was written
down nobody really believed we'd have
any way of testing it but it was a great
mathematical construction to explain the
universe now we actually think we can
test some very explicit consequences of
the model and they are basically the
ripples in the fruitcake there are
ripples that are imprinted on the cake
part of the fruitcake and we are trying
to measure those and we now have the
sensitivity even though the fruitcake is
very finely grained and the ripples are
very very subtle
we could we think we can see them so
this is about to happen and if you see
that then you know where the fruitcake
came from
you